- Hey, everyone, it's Mark Wiens.
I am hanging out with Mike Chen.
- What's up, guys?
- He's an amazing food lover.
And we're gonna take you on
a noodle tour of Bangkok.
we're gonna eat some of the best noodles
and a well-rounded
variety of Thai noodles.
- Noodles are one of my favorite things
and we both love spicy food as well.
- Yes, we do.
- So, I think we're gonna
get along pretty well.
- It's gonna be an awesome day.
(upbeat music)
In this video, Mike and I
are taking you on an ultimate
Thai street food noodle tour of Bangkok,
where you'll discover five
different Thai noodle dishes
that you don't want to miss
eating when you're in Thailand.
We had to begin this tour with
something big and beautiful.
And I'm talking about one of
the most impressive, giant,
bubbling pans of meat
you'll find in Bangkok.
The first restaurant, this
place is called Wattana Panich.
And this place is legendary in Bangkok
for their beef noodles,
their braised beef noodles,
Chinese-Thai style and
the absolute best thing,
or the icon of this restaurant is their,
it's almost like a jacuzzi
of this eternal bubbling
beef parts and juices and oils and fats.
- That was the craziest things
I've seen in Bangkok so far.
And there's different
parts of cow in there.
- You can see everything.
If you just gaze across
the surface of that pan
you see beef chunks, you see
tripe, you see intestines,
you see other unknown parts.
- [Mike] And you're telling
me that this thing is,
like, eternal.
- Yeah, they never turn off the fire.
Which brews beneath there.
This is called kuay teow neua tukyang.
So it's beef noodles with everything.
There's some beef balls in there.
And it also includes both
braised beef and also fresh beef.
- [Mike] So I mean, do
they have hot oil here?
- They don't have hot oil.
Usually the Thai seasonings
is chili vinegar.
Chili flakes and fish sauce.
All right, let's go in for the broth.
You can see how thick and rich that is.
- Oh, that is fatty, that is fatty.
- [Mark And Mike] Cheers, man.
- Oh my God, that is, whoa.
- Oh, it's good.
- That thing, that thing,
that broth can afford
to fly first class, that's how rich it is.
I mean, wow.
- Oh, man.
It's like, you can actually
taste like the fatty collagen
thickness of that, man.
- I almost had to chew that broth.
- Soup number five.
Soup number five.
Here it is.
The soup number five.
- I don't know what that means.
But I'm a little scared.
It looks, I see Chinese
herbs in there already.
But I'm excited, I'm excited.
Whatever you're bringing out, I'll eat it.
- [Mark] Okay, so should we
season our noodles first?
Then we can proceed on with the other.
- [Mike] How do you typically
season your noodles?
- [Mark] Normally, this
is just crushed up chilis,
marinated in vinegar.
- [Mike] I see that a
lot here in Thailand.
- [Mark] Normally, do you like it sour?
- [Mike] I do.
- [Mark] I love it sour, so.
- [Mike] Thank you, yeah.
Load it in, absolutely.
- [Mark] Probably like.
- [Mike] Yeah, absolutely.
- Scoops of that.
Usually this is not really spicy.
But it's just fragrant.
And the spice comes from
the ground red chili.
So this is more for sourness.
- And then we got the heat coming up.
I'm like, I just shovel it in.
It's okay.
- [Mark] Usually about two scoops or so.
Two scoops should do it.
- [Mike] This is where
things get beautiful.
- Oh, look at that.
You can see the color of
that broth just goes from
that dark brown color
to like a maroon almost.
- Oh.
Dude.
That just made it magical.
That's ridiculous.
You know, it has all the elements I like.
Flavorful, it's vinegary.
Man, that beef is flavorful.
That beef is really flavorful.
- [Mark] Did you try the braised beef?
- Yeah.
I mean, I think I had a
piece with a little bit
of tendon in there.
But this piece looks
really braised actually.
- Oh yeah.
Oh the braised beef is so tender.
That broth, yeah you just gotta drink it.
- I'm not even being civilized here.
- It's so good.
- [Mike] Let's move on
to our second item here.
- [Mark] Okay.
- [Mike] What do we got here?
- I think this one is goat.
And then this one is bull penis.
Soup number five.
- Oh, so that's the mysterious soup.
I knew that the way you
said that I was like,
number five, I think
something is off with that.
- Are we going straight in here?
Or should we taste the soup first.
- Okay, let's taste the soup first.
- Let's taste the soup first.
- Ease our way in.
- It is very thick.
- Okay.
- Okay, the soup is good.
- [Mark] Oh, it's good.
It's amazing.
- [Mike] That soup is good.
- It's so herbal.
I think we should go in for
bigger and better things now.
Oh.
It's actually incredible.
- [Mike] I don't know if I
would use the word incredible.
It's different.
- [Mark] Oh, I love it actually.
- [Mike] It's sort of
like, it's really soft.
But not too slimy.
- [Mark] A little bit slimy.
- It's a little slimy.
It's got a little aftertaste to it.
Was there a little bitterness to it?
I think I'm good with that one bite.
I mean.
- Man, I really love it.
Almost like intestines.
- [Mike] Yeah, less chewy.
- But even less chewy.
They're softer.
Should we move into the other one?
- Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do a piece of lean meat here.
All right, cool.
Yours got bones in it, you
gotta be a little careful.
- Yeah, yeah.
I'll kind of nibble around the bones here.
- [Mike] I'm just gonna
one bite this thing.
- Oh.
- Oh, that's nice.
- Oh, that just melts in your mouth.
- That's great.
- After that stunning bowl of
beef noodles and that soup,
we, Mike and I are just here
admiring the jacuzzi of beef.
- [Mike] It's like
watching a meaty sunset.
You can't look away.
- I could just stare
into that all day long.
And they actually use a shovel.
To like scrape off all of that beefy fat
that's probably caramelized
on the bottom of the pan.
- You can't have it burned, so.
- It's just the cycle of
flavor that never ends.
(upbeat music)
We just made it to the next restaurant.
Mike, we're gonna eat here pad see ew.
Like a fried noodles with soy sauce.
Thick noodles, yup.
- Oh, I'm excited.
Is that what people call
drunken noodles in the States?
- It's a little bit
different, but same noodles.
Same actual like rice noodles.
Standing here at the
front of the restaurant
watching them cook and
assemble the noodles,
and especially watching
him make that pad see ew,
it's just incredible.
He puts in the egg and
the meat and then just
scratches it around on
the extremely hot wok.
And the smoke just billows.
So they actually have a chimney.
And they have like fiber glass windows
so that it blocks in all the smoke.
Otherwise this entire
restaurant would just
be filled with the smoke.
This place is called Nay Lao Radna Yodpak.
And this place specializes
in two main noodle dishes.
One of them is called radna.
Which is, it's a noodle
dish with gravy sauce.
And the other dish is called pad see ew.
Which is stir fried Thai
noodles with soy sauce.
This restaurant is just buzzing right now.
And partly because we're here
right at the lunch time rush.
- I can't wait.
This is my first time
eating a noodle dish I love
in the country of its origin.
- And there's an egg fried within here.
There's pork, there's, I see the pork.
- Cheers, my friend.
- Cheers, man.
- [Mike] Dude.
- [Mark] Oh, the smokiness
of those noodles.
- That is really good.
I'll be honest, I mean, I don't know,
it doesn't look like much.
But holy cow, that flavor.
- You can just see a cloud
of smoke that's rising
from the wok as he's cooking it.
So you know it's gonna have that smoky,
that deep smoky flavor.
- That is something you
never have in the U.S.
- I think what we should do though is,
we should try the other pad see ew first.
To like compare that same flavor.
Another version of pad see ew.
- [Mike] Yeah, let's do it.
- [Mark] Just with different noodles.
And with an extra omelet on top.
So it's an extra egg
is always a good idea.
- And some gailan, of course.
That was, can I say it?
That was all about the egg.
The egg is fluffy.
But slightly like almost like
caramelized on the edges.
I mean the noodles are
great, noodles are great.
But that egg was the star.
- All right, Mike.
Third bowl of noodles,
this one is the radna
which is the gravy sauce with noodles.
So this is like a different composition
of a noodle dish here.
- [Mike] Let's do it.
- [Mark] And it's a thick gravy.
But then the same ingredients.
The same rice noodles.
The gailan, the pork in here.
- [Mike] I feel like
that's a common theme.
- [Mark] You just admire the
stickiness of that sauce.
- Oh.
That pork is ridiculous.
I do feel like this needs some acid.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Vinegar and chilis.
Has to be done.
- [Mike] It's gonna come down to that.
- Vinegar.
- Yup.
- Maybe a few more of these chilis.
- Do it.
- And then yeah, the chili.
Hit it with the chili, man.
- [Mike] Let's make it rain.
- That's a beautiful rain.
- Oh.
I love it.
- Oh yeah.
- [Mike] Okay, so mix it up a little bit.
Mix it up a little bit.
- Get a goo going.
This is one of those noodles
dishes where you almost
have to like, kind of like eat it fast
before it slides out of your spoon.
- Yeah, this is not gonna
be pretty, just saying.
- [Mark] I love it with
the vinegar, though.
We need them to top this
with another omelet.
- I think so.
That omelet is like my
favorite thing on this dish.
- Oh, oh, that's good.
- I love them both.
I feel like, I don't know.
How do you choose?
It's like if you have two kids,
who do you choose?
You wanna keep 'em both.
But I think the omelet from
here to this dish right here,
that's be my perfect.
- [Mark] Cool.
- [Mike] But this place is fantastic.
- We ordered his wish.
His dream come true.
The wide rice noodles pad see
ew with the omelet on top.
- [Mike] This is beautiful,
thank you so much
for thinking of me while on the way.
I think this is the dream team right here.
- [Mark] That was good.
- I'm so happy.
- That pad see ew was stunning, actually.
The smokiness of that charred
flavor of those noodles
was unbelievable.
- At least Thai noodles,
you ruined it for me.
- And we are on our way next
to go eat boat noodles.
- [Mike] Oh wow.
- Yup, this is it right here.
(speaking foreign language)
To make Thai boat noodles,
they first added some
seasonings to a bowl.
Blanched the rice noodles
in fresh morning glory.
And doused it in the thick
murky and full of flavor
pig's blood broth.
This is the pig's blood here.
Raw pig's blood.
- That's raw pig's blood.
- [Mark] Then she takes it
and then she dumps it into the soup
to slightly cook it and
then that makes the broth.
- [Mike] Wow.
- Mike, look at all these boat noodles.
And this restaurant is
called Khon Mee Sen.
And this is a little
bit off the beaten path.
This is a restaurant near
to Pad Kret in Nonthaburi,
so we're probably about 20
kilometers outside of central
downtown Bangkok.
And I've been to this
boat noodle restaurant.
But it's probably been a couple years ago.
And again, we got two different noodles.
We got the sen lak, which is
the medium sized rice noodle.
And the sen mee which are
the thin rice noodles.
- [Mike] So the broth is extremely thick.
- [Mark] Yeah, you can, oh man.
It's almost like a gravy.
Kind of slurp it all down
in a one biter, if you want.
- Cheers.
- I'll admit.
This just kind of scares me.
'Cause blood scares me.
Because I'm not a vampire.
And I had this in New York
where the soup, it was more soup.
Than like saucy noodles.
But this, I can't really
tell there's blood in here.
- The blood really acts to rich it.
And really like, for me it
really enhances the flavor.
I love it.
And I got a big piece
of liver in that bite.
And if you can see the liver,
the liver is half raw as well.
- I see that.
- [Mark] And it's awesome.
The liver, it just melts in your mouth.
- [Mike] With a bit vinegar.
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
- [Mike] I think it will be awesome.
- [Mark] You have to, man.
- [Mike] Let me hook you up.
- You have to, thank you.
Another thing that complements,
That I feel complements
the boat noodles so well
is sweet basil.
- Yeah.
- And you can just grab.
You can either just chase it,
or you can toss some leaves in there.
I might have to spoon it on this, man.
- Yeah, yeah.
No, do what you gotta do.
- I'm gonna spoon it.
So we can get, you can
maximize the amount we can get
in one single bite.
Oh no, my basil.
- It just, we gotta just make sure
we don't leave anything out.
All right, cheers.
- Cheers.
- That's fantastic.
I mean, the flavor is so rich.
And again, not, no blood taste at all.
- [Mark] Delicious.
Load up with some bean sprouts even.
- That'll give it some nice crunch.
- That basil is where it's at, though.
- [Mike] There you go.
- Thank you, man.
These chili flakes are amazing.
Stir this around.
All right, next bowl.
- Fantastic.
Fantastic.
- [Mark] Stack up the bowls.
- [Mike] Whoa, is this pork rind?
- [Mark] You crunch it up
inside the boat noodles.
And that gives it the
extra crunchy dimension.
- [Mike] Wow.
- And that is what takes your boat noodles
to a final level of excellence.
Oh yeah.
- Oh.
That is awesome.
- It's like a crunch sponge.
All right.
- [Mike] All right.
- We just finished with the boat noodles.
That was extremely satisfying.
So good.
- Coma setting in.
Boat noodle coma.
- Again, you can feel free
to lean your chair back, man.
- If I'm not quiet here for
about 30 minutes, I'm gone.
- I'll make sure to stay
awake 'cause I'm driving.
We're driving on our way
to the next restaurant.
That was a little bit of a long drive,
but we made it to an area.
This area is called Saphan Kwai.
- I smell durian.
Right now.
- Oh, it's right there, hello.
That smells delicious.
We're gonna head over to
what is one of my favorite
street food styles for
bamee, which is egg noodles.
Saphan Kwai is a real Bangkok
Thai street food paradise.
There's a lot of good
street food in this area.
This place is called Uwan
Bamee Giew Guangdong.
And this is one of my favorite
just simple street food
restaurants in Bangkok.
He is a master of bamee
which are egg noodles.
And he makes the egg noodles
fresh himself every day.
He kind of like loosens the noodles.
He boils them for the
perfect amount of time.
You can tell that he's an artist.
He drops them into the bowl.
Then he kind of fishes around the soup.
He fishes out some of those dumplings.
And then adds in the different sauces.
I ordered for us the bamee giew moo daeng.
And this is egg noodles
with dumplings in here.
You got the shrimp dumplings.
And then moo daeng is
the, it's the Thai version
of cha siu.
But it's a little bit different.
It's kind of Thai-ified.
- Is there a reason why there's
always a fish ball in here?
- There's always at least one.
- Like one.
There's always, we
always get one fish ball.
- I think it's just that
whole variety of meats
and everything.
And I love how he just kind of
handles the noodles artfully
before he blanches them.
He just, he knows his
noodles so well like a child.
Oh.
Oh, I love it.
- [Mike] I got a beautiful
crispy pork skin with mine.
And that provided such
a contrast in texture.
- [Mark] The noodles
are so light and fluffy.
Because they're so so thin.
- It's really springy.
Really springy.
- [Mark] They don't have
any of that kind of like
floury taste.
- The filling is excellent.
Right?
- It almost has a bacon taste to it.
- Beautiful, beautiful.
I wanna try some of this
soup in there a little bit.
- Yeah, you can do that too.
- Oh yeah, the soup is very light.
Very light in flavor.
And I don't know about
you, but whenever I see
a meat on a bone, my Chinese instinct
is just telling me to gnaw on it.
Oh.
This is one of those bones that,
meats off the bones that the more you chew
the more the flavor releases.
You don't.
- It's just like creamy
porky goodness, man.
- You don't get a release of
flavor in this first bite.
But as you chew it, you're like, wow.
The depths of the flavor,
it's hidden inside.
- That's been boiled for a
very long time, you know that.
- And I got a piece
where I got the collagen
so it's little crunchy bones.
- I got a little something
gelatinous on that bite.
But they would definitely
be better with some chili.
- [Mike] Oh yeah, yeah.
Heck yeah.
- [Mark] And vinegar.
- [Mike] Heck yeah.
Here, you want a whole spoon full?
- [Mark] Yes, please.
- [Mike] Thank you.
- [Mark] You wanna put some vinegar?
- [Mike] Yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
(upbeat music)
And I'm gonna go ahead and
add this in my broth as well.
- [Mark] Oh yeah.
- I'm gonna have my noodles take a dive.
And right there, that's a 10 pointer.
- Just look at that, the
beauty of these noodles.
They all have their own
personality, every noodle.
- [Mike] It's cascading spice right there.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's,
oh, that's beautiful.
- [Mike] That's like
a waterfall of beauty.
- [Mark] Oh, man.
- That's a spice waterfall.
That looked wonderful.
Dude.
- What a bite, man, what a bite.
That was superb.
I loved it.
Every single bite of it.
(speaking foreign language)
- That was great.
- What did you think, Mike?
- That was probably the best egg noodles
I've had outside of Hong Kong.
- Cool.
- And I love everything
they threw in there.
(upbeat music)
- We've been walking
around for a little while.
And we actually just
kind of ran out of time
to go to more famous pad thai restaurant.
But there's this restaurant
that's very close
to where we just had the egg noodles.
It's called Pad Thai Je Tim.
I know nothing about this place.
I've never been here.
But let's check it out.
Let's see how it is.
To make pad thai, he
first tossed in some tofu.
A spoonful of dried shrimp.
And then a few fresh shrimp.
He then cracked in a couple of eggs.
Let them hiss and sizzle.
Before adding in the main
pad thai rice noodles.
To season, he added in a
number of different sauces
including a sweet tangy tamarind sauce.
(upbeat music)
All right, Mike.
I gotta tell you, pad thai is
not really one of my favorite
noodle dishes, Thai noodle dishes.
- But it is traditional Thai cuisine.
- Yeah, yeah, it is popular in Thailand.
But I think sometimes it
gets even more of publicity
because it's so famous
outside of Thailand.
It's a dish, noodle
dish that's usually more
on the sweet side.
Which is why it's not
my preference of a dish.
But it's, it can be good.
And I don't eat it that often.
So it's gonna be good
to try this pad thai.
- I'm excited.
I mean, like you said,
it is really popular.
It's number one probably
number one Thai dish item
that we eat, at least in the U.S.
So I'm excited to see the difference
of authentic version than what we have
back in the States.
Why is this in a omelet?
- Yeah, so this one is,
it's called a haw kai.
So they wrap it in a egg.
It's actually it's the
same type of noodle.
They fried it in the same batch.
- [Mike] But they wrap it in an omelet.
- [Mark] This one is just
with shrimp but then this one
they wrapped in omelet.
- I feel like that's pretty ingenious.
I'm gonna cut this in half
so we can kind of see the anatomy
of this pad thai omelet thingie.
- There's tofu in there.
There's also dried shrimp.
As well as big shrimp, fresh shrimp.
Oh yeah.
- Here we go.
Oh.
That is good.
- Like it?
- You can give your
verdict, expert verdict.
But to somebody who just
had pad thai in Thailand
for the first time, that's really good.
- Cool.
- To me that's really good.
I don't know, what do you think?
- It's okay.
It's okay.
But like I said, I'm not huge on the dish.
Pad thai in the first place.
- But,
so as a pad thai,
I know you don't love this dish.
But as a dish itself, compared
to the other ones you've had
in this country,
is this just okay, right, still?
- I think it's okay, yeah.
Other versions that have again, other like
street food versions,
they'd have more of a smoky,
you taste the smoke point on it.
So yeah, I've had better versions.
- So I'm gonna take a bite
of this banana leaf thing.
- Oh yeah, that's good.
It's chalky.
- Why's it doing weird
things to my tongue?
Wow.
- It has a very chalkiness to it.
And kind of a little bit of a bitterness.
The other pad thai, and this
is just pad thai goong sod.
Which is just with fresh shrimp.
And gotta season that
with the wedge of lime.
- [Mike] Can we use this chili powder?
- Yes, please.
On those peanuts.
All right.
- Cheers.
- You wanna chase that with some chives?
- Yeah, yeah, let's do it.
- I love the chives, man.
- Really good.
- They're quite mild.
So not only a lot of good noodles,
but that was a lot of fun.
Tasting all those
different types of noodles.
All in a single day.
What was your favorite?
- Definitely the first place we went to.
- The beef noodles.
- With, especially with the omelet.
In the wide noodles.
- Oh, the fried noodle one.
- Yeah, yeah, the pad see ew, yeah.
With the omelet on top,
it was transformative.
- Oh yeah.
Oh, that was good.
Oh, I'd almost forgotten about that place.
How could I?
- [Mike] Yeah, that was delicious.
- That was delicious.
So go check out Mike's channel.
He's Strictly Dumpling.
Link will be in the description box.
Check out his awesome
food and travel videos.
And that's it for this video.
Thank you again for watching.
Please remember to give
this video a thumbs up.
Love to hear from you in
the comments section below.
And if you're not already subscribed,
click subscribe now for lots
more food and travel videos.
Good bye from Bangkok, thank
you again for watching.
- See you later.